brothers and sisters have been asking us
to react to the new Piers Morgan versus
Andrew Tate debate let's take a look at
it
joins me again now Andrew good to see
you salaam alaikum Pierce good to see
you I I'm genuinely been Amazed by the
reaction I've had in the streets not
just here and I went to Qatar for the
World Cup had the same thing there a lot
of people coming up about because John
Ronaldo obviously but also a lot of
people coming up about you and they were
almost exclusively men young men who
genuinely see you as a role model as
somebody who inspires them as somebody
they want to be like yeah so they made
me think the first interview you have is
quite combative the second time a
shortened to be less so I want to try
and work out in this one who you are
because it struck me as extraordinary
that Google this week revealed some
stats for the year the number one person
whose name followed people Google
searching who is in 2022 was Andrew Tate
yeah that it's quite remarkable I think
there's a whole swath of the population
especially young men that feel
disenfranchised they feel
disenfranchised with the media machine
and the things they're supposed to
believe they don't feel an affinity with
the Educational Systems or the culture
and they look at a person like me who
stands up and says to things that many
young men think I haven't put a magic
spell on the world the fact that people
like what I say means that they agree
with me deep inside they may be afraid
to say it themselves but I am seen as a
Bastion of free speech and a Bastion
Bastion from masculinity as a whole
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about do you think you're a
Force for good or are you a force in
evolution where perhaps you've done and
said stuff you shouldn't have done and
as you get older perhaps as you get
bigger more follow around the world you
sense a responsibility perhaps you
didn't have early on well we all evolve
every human evolves day by day you
wouldn't be human if you didn't evolve
on an hour-by-hour basis but I do not
think I'm a Force for good I absolutely
know I am a Force for good because I'm a
force for truth and truth is a good
thing without truth we're going to end
up in absolute tyranny and slavery and
we're already on our way there I feel
like we're starting to combat it my
cancellation was the beginning of a
change in public Consciousness Elon
having Twitter is another beginning of
the change in public Consciousness and
anybody who stands up and speaks what
they truly believe even if it's
something I don't personally agree with
I think that truth is absolutely
important and people's personal truths
and people's personal opinions even on
differing sides of the same opinion
should be heard this is one of the most
deadly Terror groups in the world
absolutely they committed a series of
appalling the chocolate sure killing
innocent people left right center how
could you possibly have satisfaction
well if it's the video I'm recollecting
it's the video we're talking about it's
about the fact that I believe Isis was
funded by the Western created by the
West in the first place and it wasn't a
degree of satisfaction like I'm happy
Isis exists it was a commentary on the
world well here's what you said Isis are
the real Muslims because Isis do exactly
what the book says kill everyone is not
a Muslim and chop people's heads off and
set them on fire and be raging lunatics
but all the other Muslims go they're not
real Muslims because I read the book and
ignore those parts well then you're not
an effing Muslim because you're ignoring
the effing book
that's an interesting that's an
interesting point you've just raised
because I am now Islamic and it's it's
funny because I used to be an atheist
and when you're an atheist you believe
that religion causes more problems than
it fixes and then you come to a
realization and you start to learn the
truth of yourself and the truth of God
and you realize that religion is
actually the cure for most of the
problems in the world and godlessness is
the problem in the world so that is
something I will apologize for admit I
was wrong about because I was atheistic
and now as a Muslim I understand that's
absolutely not the case if that's a
particular video you're talking about
then then well that's really interesting
so you you regret saying that yeah
because you learn and you grow and you
evolve as I said at the time I believe
did because I didn't believe in God at
the time it was a very long time ago
it's actually kind of a testament to you
peers you manage to find the oldest
possible videos of me that have ever
existed but at the time I was atheistic
well no I was curious because you have
recently converted to Islam correct so
these questions I think are pertinent to
your conversion absolutely as to what
you actually believe as a practicing
Muslim uh yeah I believe that Islam is
beautiful I believe it's the last True
Religion on Earth it's certainly the
last respected religion on Earth and I
felt differently inside since I've
converted and I think it has the salute
solutions to a lot of the problems we're
facing in the world today
that particular video was once again
satirical a lot of people watching this
would not have seen it they would not
seen the joke element of it it's fine it
but it's not funny no well you know it's
like most of the time as we discussed in
our first interview with me things are
taken out of context short form etc etc
but
all in all you could say the same things
about Christians if you were to read the
Old Testament and say stick to the Old
Testament you'd kill anyone who works on
a Sunday so it's not applicable to you
women's consonants violence a second you
don't countenance violence I absolutely
do not countenance violence when I was
talking about violence being the bottom
line salute the bottom line decider
between disagreeing points of view it's
not I'm calling for violence I'm just
making a commentary on how the world
genuinely functions but when you use a
word like satisfaction
you understand that people will watch
that and think how can you possibly find
any form of terrorism satisfying I don't
find any form of terrorism satisfying I
don't find Western terrorism satisfying
either I don't think it's satisfying
that we managed to find five hundred
thousand dollars per bomb to drop on
some farmer who makes four dollars a day
under the name of freedom and and we
can't seem to pay our nurses enough to
do their jobs I don't find any kind of
terrorism and it's actually very
interesting you talk about the world
terrorism terrorist and freedom fighter
good guy and bad guy all of this is
subjective there are people who believe
that the west of the biggest terrorists
on the Earth are people who believe that
America causes more Wars than anyone
else and they've killed more people than
anyone else and there's people who
believe the absolute opposite so once
again it depends who you're talking to
is the subjective conversation there's
no black and white in the world there's
areas of gray and that's how it is so I
thought you were talking about another
video where I was saying the Isis is
standing up and fighting for what they
believe in I'm not saying what they
believe in is right but that's what they
were fighting for at the time and it was
a completely different video than the
one you were actually referencing that
you would condemn them now I don't
condemn anybody doing anything bad to
anybody I I'm not a person out here with
a criminal record I don't hurt anyone I
just spent my first segment on this show
talking about how I believe in Law and
Order and how important that is I think
people can operate inside of their lives
safely and walk around man woman child
can walk around in safety in any City
they live in I didn't I I saw some clips
of it but I didn't see that whole middle
to end segment so it's really just very
refreshing to me alhamdulillah well he's
definitely right about the matter of
perspectives because I believe that the
West are you know the biggest I'd say
arbitrators of violence in the world I
would say that they are the biggest
for opponents of violence in the world
and human uh Injustice in the world I
will say that firmly for many different
reasons whether it's you know American
businesses using sweatshops and other
places whether it's America funding is
able to
Assyria and Palestinian people and
remove them from their homes and
ethnically cleanse them I think like
when you just look at the worst and how
they destabilize Africa and destabilize
the Middle East and they were doing well
they didn't need the West to save them
you know but the West has this like
almost like this you know savior complex
the white man's spirit and they kind of
use that to legitimize a lot of the
colonialism and imperialism that's been
going on today I think they're just
atrocious it's backwards it's not
necessary but you can kind of see how it
just kind of blew up in their face no
pun intended because look at the West
snow look at the suicide rates look at
the mental health or I should say lack
of mental dysfunction you know and
compare that to the Eastern countries
bro oh it's it's not the white mindset
it's not the worst mindset it's the
Conquistador mindset because this comes
from before America was even America
this comes from when the Spanish
actually came over and uh invaded the
lands and basically conquered the uh the
natives that with Abram they were coming
and they were it's almost like they were
saving these people but in reality they
were just you know
basically finishing a lot of them off it
sounds real off there
yeah they were they were killing a lot
of them
and they were
you know
don't need that anymore yeah yeah
they definitely did horrendous things a
lot of a lot of different places what
they actually the Muslims I would say
are one of the very few
um Nations that when they invaded a
place they didn't commit Mass atrocities
I believe there were some Muslim rulers
that were like absolutely vile and
disgusting do not follow Islamic law and
uh they did you know horrible things to
Muslims and non-muslims but generally
speaking if you look at the prophet Fiji
upon if you look at the sahaba if you
look at the good rulers that follow
Islam you'll find that when they you
know conquered a place they would not
you know just do what the Mongols did to
the Muslims which one was one of the
most brutalities in history the worst
brutalities in history but when you look
at the West it's really sad because for
them they justify it with some very
shallow and fallacious circular argument
which if I was gonna try and explain it
I would say they assume that liberalism
and democracy is good then they look at
these other people they don't have
liberacy they don't have liberalism
Liberty democracy okay so that therefore
we should attack these places we should
colonize them we should take over and
enforce liberalism and democracy on them
and then when they're asked why do you
do that they say well because it's a
good thing to do so it's just a circular
argument they start with liberalism and
Liberty and democracy and say these
things are good they do all these
horrible actions and when they're asked
why they're allowed to do it well
because these things are good who
decided you guys are the arbitrators of
what ideology is good or best did even
in your own Democratic View and position
if you go to those people and give them
pure democracy what do you guys want
according to statistics in these Muslim
countries they would want sharing Allah
to begin with so it's completely
fallacious to begin with and so I see
what he's saying he says that they're
the biggest arbitrators but he doesn't
say this word for word but they are the
biggest arbitrators of these uh
and we're not even talking about the
hypocrisy of the Westborough we're not
even talking about the hypocrisy you
know there's a new there's a new Avatar
movie I'm sure you guys heard about that
you know the first Avatar movie that
came out probably like 10 20 years ago
the new one that came out I personally
haven't seen it I don't support it
because this the I think the producer
director of Avatar James Cameron he
recently said an interview that
testosterone is a toxin that everyone
should aim to basically work out of
their system
he literally called the male hormone
testosterone something that's literally
the root of societal evil and we should
all aim to basically cleanse our system
of this toxin but I find it enriching
that this is what modern mainstream
Western propaganda makes you think toxic
masculine and you know testosterone the
bad thing but if a 10 year old girl
wants to basically be injected with this
same toxin we should use our taxpayer
money and kind of fund that you know
what I mean it's it's so hypocritical
bro and it's just [ __ ] bro to say
the least
but this is the disease of the worst so
hmm
this is the disease of the West we were
talking on the phone you have you have
so much freedom you have so much Freedom
that look what it does to your mind and
it starts making making you think in an
delusional way
hmm
and I speak from experience man I've
been living in the west since I was a
kid so who who better to say this than
someone who's actually lived in the
belly of the Beast guys tomorrow Friday
inshallah we will be going live with
Sony fast part two insha Allah this is
going to be a game changer we're gonna
basically reflect on some of the things
that we said we were going to reflect on
in this little two to three week time
after the stream and inshaallah we'll
see what happens make sure you guys stay
tuned 6 p.m Eastern Standard time
tomorrow one thing I noticed about Piers
Morgan too is constantly changing the
goal post bro and this is the thing with
the West they don't have anything solid
to stand on the gourami always talks
about they don't have anything objective
in terms of morality so Piers Morgan
this character you'll see him a lot
talking about oh you know the Eastern
countries the Middle East they don't
give women their rights they don't do
this but then when it comes here he's
not really supporting you know Alpha
began culture in schools and he thinks
this this whole you know T in the
alphabet gang is outrageous and
hypocritical and you know men competing
in women's sports [ __ ] you know so
it makes sense that he has a lot of
things right but then also has a lot of
things wrong and I genuinely believe
until he finds Islam he will never know
what the goal posts are
oh you never know man I do tell you
might be the one that's influencing him
may Allah got Pierce Morgan bro I mean
that means I mean
Toronto bro as a Reaver especially
someone growing up in the west do you
see a lot of things
holding weight in terms of what Andrew
did is saying that the West in a way
kind of forgets about its own people
forgets about its own corruption forgets
about cleaning its own water and gives
too much concern about women's rights
let's say in Pakistan or like other
rights in other countries
it's a I think it's a diversion tactic
and I mean look at that I don't I don't
know I'm not a part of the uh the system
I don't partake in it so I can't really
tell you if it's a truth or not but it
just makes the most sense you know like
the West has always been trying to
divert people from its main actions its
main intentions
like they've had um like there was just
one thing over here in America called
the uh the Boston bombing
and when that happened they had like
this one thing that had like gone
through in the court system that if
people would have known about they could
have
um appealed it they could have like
voted against it and basically shut it
down but because everyone was so focused
on the bus and bombing everyone just
completely lost sight and did not see
that there was this a bill being passed
I forgot what the bill was I think
releasing our uh rights over our privacy
in terms of the internet I might I might
have that wrong so if if someone's
interested they can Google it up that's
like what was the thing that passed
during this time frame during the Boston
bombing and um it's just crazy like
there they diverted people's attention
um you have things like
uh 911 they diverted people's attention
from something else it's always been a
diversion tactic it's been taking the
the attention away from like what
they're really trying to do so like I
wouldn't doubt I wouldn't doubt that
this is what they do for every other
thing though
um
all right with that being said
foreign
foreign
Muslims in Norway are now establishing a
message and Tower Center to enhance the
Norwegian dower if you donate to the
schools you will ensure Allah reap the
rewards of thousands of Muslims coming
back to Islam and many of those who
become Dwight and invite Islam so click
the link and donate now and share the
video for extra Rewards